foreign
hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion last episode we took a deep dive
into the emerging battle for AI
Supremacy between Google and openai with
Microsoft's backing just a couple of
days later both Microsoft and Google
came out with their announcements it's
just crazy how fast things are moving so
how did each company go with their
announcements
well very differently Microsoft gave an
awe-inspiring presentation while Google
scrambled and fumbled a Google presenter
became embarrassed and flustered when
she realized that there was no phone to
give a live demonstration of what she
was talking about Investors weren't so
impressed either so Google's parent
company alphabet lost 100 billion
dollars worth of value during and after
the presentation so sit back relax and
enjoy the show as we take a look at the
biggest war in technology in a very long
time
[Music]
you are watching cool Fusion TV
first of all I mean look I have the
greatest of admirations uh for Google
and what they've done and you know
they're they're an unbelievable company
they're the 800 pound gorilla on this
which is uh what they are and I hope
that with our Innovation
um they will definitely want to come out
and show that they can dance and I want
people to know that we made them dance
and I think that'll be a great day the
race for AI dominance is heating up on
February 7th Microsoft fires the first
shot across the bow at Google they
unveil their grand plan for AI then the
next day Google shoots back and unveils
their AI
to say that both presentations were
unequal would be an understatement so
let's start with Microsoft
CEO Satya Nadella takes to the stage he
talks about how every Walk of Life is
beginning to be changed by AI then goes
on to talk about the three stages of the
web its birth on PCS and servers than
mobile and apps and then the next phase
will be AI
Satya and the rest of Microsoft have
begun to see an issue with search the
fact is search hasn't changed in 20
years and some people think that Google
has gotten even less accurate lately
because of SEO keyword stuffing
Microsoft's new edge browser and Bing
will be able to do three new things
answer your questions chat with you and
create new things
to highlight some interesting insights
into the current shortfalls of search
they mentioned the statistic that forty
percent of people search for something
and immediately click back out of the
result that they got this means that
they can't find what they're looking for
and they calculated that about half of
all searches don't get the answers that
you want most of these are very specific
queries based on your personal situation
Microsoft showed a chart highlighting
the issue you've got search on the
x-axis and generative AI on the y-axis
the new Bing will bridge that gap
between the two giving you the power of
traditional search with the helpfulness
of the good people on Reddit
this chart specifically reminds me of
the unveiling of the iPod and iPhone
where Steve Jobs clearly laid out a gap
in the market and showed where a new
product could fit in to solve it I think
this chart might be historic in the same
way
so getting onto the new Bing itself it's
running on AI that is quote much more
powerful than chat GPT and tuned
specifically for search
in the presentation Microsoft states
that because they already have a search
engine they can now use back-end web
indexing and data to efficiently and
directly tie into the new version of
chat GPT
so onto the new Bing interface when you
type a complex query you'll get the
typical results on the left and on the
right you'll get a synthesized answer
with sourcing you can ask about current
events or future events and get the same
experience
particularly cool example was asking if
a specific seat from Ikea would fit in a
2019 Honda Odyssey if that new love seat
from Ikea is going to fit in the back of
my Honda Odyssey and what you'll see is
Bing can actually find the dimensions of
the love seat
the Interior Space of the car and then
make an estimation as to whether it will
fit
in this case I'm choosing an example of
where Bing does not know the answer
and we know and we know that we can't be
definitive about it and the reason I'm
doing that is because we know we won't
be able to answer every question every
time but Bing can still provide some
helpful information as you can see on
this answer
we also know we'll make our share of
mistakes and as we begin to roll this
out so we've added a quick feedback
button at the top of every search so
that you can give us feedback and we can
learn
but this was just the beginning the main
feature was the new chat section think
of this a search with your own personal
helper to help you refine your query
until you get exactly what you're
looking for
this comes in handy for activities like
trip planning and shopping research
let's start with shopping
so I'm going to look for a 65 inch TV we
give you a good set of answers but now I
want to refine this query so I can do
that by going to chat now I can either
swipe up with my fingers or look up here
at the top of the screen we have now a
new chat scope and with that with one
click you are now into chat look how
beautiful that is search to chat just so
seamless so you can really you can just
talk to it you can just ask for it so in
this case let's say I'm going to ask for
a gaming optimized TV
all I have to say is which of these are
best for gaming
and we remember all of the context since
we know you're asking about gaming TVs
we pull out oh this one has a game
Optimizer this has game mode and so we
make that really helpful I'm on a budget
I'll ask you to adjust it for uh which
one of these is the cheapest here I
didn't know you could get a flat screen
for under 500 but that's a good deal
there on Bing if you're looking for a TV
Engadget elaborates a bit more about how
the experience was basically think of
this layout as the physical
manifestation of what Microsoft is
calling your AI co-pilot in here you're
encouraged to be way more conversational
than you would be with say Bing's
regular search bar or even a Google
search so after you get your initial
round of answers from Bing you can
follow up with questions without all
Every Little Bit of the keywords or
contacts you provided earlier and the
system will still know what it is that
you're talking about in fact it'll keep
all the context until you hit that sweep
or the broom icon to the left of the
input field to start a new topic and
clean the Slate altogether so Microsoft
has also added AI into their edge
browser you can for example pull up a
PDF ask questions about it summarize it
and compare it to other stuff on the web
just take a look it's pretty
mind-blowing and you're going to notice
now that we've integrated Bing in a
really cool new way
let me show you
I'm browsing around in my new edge
browser and I want to read a gaps
quarterly report and up comes the 15
page Gap PDF it's pretty long I won't
have time to read all that what I'd love
is a summary of the key points
with one click
I can open up the sidebar I can use chat
and Edge to Simply ask it to give me the
key takeaways of the page I'm on so I'll
just say key takeaways from the page and
being an AI can now read that PDF and
look how great it comes up with the
summary of the key points here very very
cool a massive Time Savings
but now I want to compare this with say
Lululemon who also has their third
quarter earnings
Bing can now call out to the web pull
information from outside of this page
bring it into Edge compare it with the
information that's on this page all with
an edge and I asked it to it in a table
and look how amazing this is
just like that in one table I can get an
answer this question think about how
much time that would have taken
otherwise
I really do have to say that's great
execution by Microsoft
there's also a new compose tab where you
can generate whatever content you'd like
specifying the tone length and other
parameters
so if you still couldn't see it with
chat GPT there's no longer any doubt the
world has just changed it's the
summation of human knowledge squeezed
into an AI or at least the start of that
process just stop and think about that
we're living through history
so what was Google's answer
unfortunately for Google everything got
off to a horrendous start Google's new
highly touted AI chat bot Bard has
already made a boo-boo the very first
advertisement for Google's Bard
showcased it giving a wrong answer after
Fortune reported on the incident
alphabet's share price began to slide in
the ad Bard is given the prompt quote
what new discoveries from the James Webb
Space Telescope can I tell my
nine-year-old about Bard responds with a
number of answers including one
suggesting the jwst was used to take the
very first pictures of a planet outside
the Earth's solar system or exoplanets
this is inaccurate the error was spotted
hours before Google hosted a launch
event for Bard in Paris where a Google
senior executive touted Bard as the
future of the company shares of Google
parent alphabet were down more than
seven percent in early trading Wednesday
outpacing declines in the broader s p
500.
the event was very disappointing very
little time was spent on The Bard
conversational AI a lot more time was
spent on reiterating how good existing
Google products were like search
translate Google lens and Maps the
elephant in the room was what Microsoft
and open AI were doing
so after 13 minutes talking about other
things they finally got onto their chat
GPT competitor powered by their research
language model Lambda
the thing was it was presented as a
standalone product what they showed was
very similar to chat GPT there was no
sourcing or further integration into any
Os or any other kinds of features Google
is basically where open AI was last year
the biggest deal for Bard is its ability
to answer questions with no one right
answer
Google calls this Nora and here's an
example
but for many questions there's no one
right answer what we call Neural queries
questions like what are the best
constellations to look for when
stargazing
for questions like those
probably won't explore a diverse range
of opinions or perspectives and be
connected to the expansive wisdom of the
weapon
that's why we bring in the magic of
generative AI directly to your search
results
so soon if you ask what are the best
constellations to look for when
stargazing new generative AI features
will help us organize complex
information and multiple viewpoints
and then of course the infamous moment
of the presentation presenter Liz Reed
was about to demonstrate multi-search a
new Google Lens feature and this is what
happened or you spot a floral pattern
shirt but you want to embley Rouge
instead
you can use multi-search for that too
let's see how that works with a live
demo foreign
[Music]
it was the most embarrassing incident in
a tech presentation since Steve Jobs
Wi-Fi wouldn't connect back in 2010. our
networks in here are always
unpredictable so they're a little
have no idea what we're going to find
they are slow today
you know you could help me out if you're
on Wi-Fi if you could just get off
appreciate it
aside from this there wasn't much else
and then the presentation just moved on
to Google Maps
overall the Google presenters seem flat
and also the live stream's comments were
turned off very unusual for a Google
event
so the event didn't provide any
groundbreaking information or much
information at all for that matter it
only signaled that Google probably isn't
prepared and doesn't have a solid plan
yet or they would have showed it
in my opinion they just shouldn't have
done the event
as mentioned 100 billion dollars of
stock value was lost due to their poor
performance
of course markets are volatile and it's
probably going to bounce back but it is
an indication of what investors
immediately thought Google No Doubt will
probably regroup and figure something
out there just isn't really another
choice for the company
Satya seems genuinely very calm cool and
collected about the whole thing the most
profitable large software business is
search so I look at this and say look I
just have to earn one user at a time an
incremental GM I've never ever
felt this liberated in terms of
opportunity in the days ahead so I'm
very excited about innovating meeting
the needs knowing that the search
category is the most profitable and
large category just on Windows Google
makes more money on Windows than all of
Microsoft so that alone should sort of
give us the impetus to really go after
this there's a great interview by The
Wall Street Journal where he behaves
like he's just stumbled across a gold
mine and I don't blame him
we are grounded in the fact that you
know Google dominates this space I I
feel like a new race is starting
with a complete new platform technology
I'm excited for the users to have Choice
finally and a real competitive race out
there how are you thinking about
monetizing this the last time I checked
software it was a search was the most
profitable category uh there is on
planet Earth so therefore all I need is
a few more users uh and someone else
that I'm competing in has to keep all of
their users and all of their gross
margin that's I love I'm looking forward
to that our intent is to do that which
is to put stuff out there with safety
but at the same time realizing that we
are going to have to think about safety
as an ongoing responsibility not a
one-time responsibility there's a lot of
fear that AI is going to take our jobs
replace us is that unfounded and how do
you think about tools like Bing now and
how we use it in the job market like I I
think of this as at the foundational
level going to help us do our jobs
better reduce some of the drudgery in
some of of our jobs whether it's in
coding or in writing or in automating
workflow or searching for information so
at the fundamental level I think we need
a productivity boost I feel it'll create
more jobs the barriers to knowledge work
will come down so I mean the unintended
consequences around labor market shifts
are always something we need to be
mindful of but I don't subscribe to this
zero sum or one lump of Labor fallacy
and I think that we're going to have new
jobs get created and more job
opportunities what about this guy
does clippy haunt your dreams not really
it's probably the thing that was the
most fun character Microsoft introduced
which you know think about it right we
have been on a 30-year journey to
perfect it so I'm excited to be here in
2023 launching Bing with AI
so one of the key things in the story is
that Microsoft has little to lose but
Google has everything to lose
Satya told the financial times that
search has changed forever and Google
has to defend their entire market share
so what about the wider discussion what
about the jobs that will be replaced
website content makers May fret AI may
have taken a lot from their businesses
it will also be interesting to see how
Publishers and content owners react to
this the chat answers are more advanced
and the simple query answers that we see
in search engines today and it's clear
that people will click on links less
even if Bing is clearly sourcing
information here there's about a billion
questions that can be raised from this
moment in history will there be lawsuits
from new sites over using their content
what about political bias and censorship
what about all the unintended
consequences
time will only tell I can only hope that
the benefits outweigh the risks and on
the bright side it's obvious to see that
there is a large benefit here
I think the next wave to excite everyone
would be an audio version of this a
smart AI assistant that has actually
good voice synthesis that's the next
step
I actually briefly mentioned this idea a
few weeks ago on the through the web
podcast so check it out if you haven't
already
so in conclusion as I said in the last
video even just a year or two ago nobody
would have thought that Google would be
in this position
from their presentation it looked like
they were unprepared and they weren't
integrating Bard as well as chat GPT was
being used but that's just me what do
you guys think anyway so that's an
update to the beginning of the AI War
I'll be interested to know your thoughts
anyway thanks for watching if you did
like this episode got a whole bunch of
stuff on AI maybe if you're wondering
how this all started and who invented AI
I've got a video on that if not there's
a bunch of other stuff on here too on
science business and Technology
it's the open watching cold fusion my
name is the gogo and I'll play you out
with yet another new track I made on the
second Channel cheers guys have a good
one
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]